hello and welcome to this video playing
non-motile one non-motile okey-dokey
so of this the modern Karpov improved
Karpov right is what they know great
just great
yes okay if you don't don't quite get
what I'm fine a mostly bright
Bishop c5 Bishop d6 Bishop c5 hmm
well I still it still feels like it is
somewhat playable I mean my position is
bad but it feels like I'm not
immediately lost that same even though
it yeah it is bad
okay so here Bishop takes I can take h3
so that is not a big problem at all
pawn takes I mean yeah it's what it is
but it's not not not extremely bad ok
night here is that an idea getting 23 I
don't I don't know if I get there early
yeah it looks old let's go back let's go
back
okay
now it looks playable
it really looks playable this is
position d5 currently hanging maybe
Knight c3 now move good night at five or
just c6 maybe just c6 okay
okay now here Knight 65 1 yeah come on
play good normal move
maybe Bishop D for him trying to trade
off my good bishop there Bishop one b6
is definitely a good piece
it looks at e3 but you know it's
probably a good choice so cheek I want
to move my queen
maybe to g5 just get some mobility for
this piece so to g5 yeah I was actually
hoping for this move I thought that
Knight f6 to g4 is kind of helpful
[Music]
maybe there may be night of three 2g5
but I can't play Quinta five at least
Nydia 3:25 if everything else fails I
think I can do that he's stepping right
into it I mean I wanted to play the move
anyway some should have three I go
Bishop g4 it looks bad for what really
looks bad
man okay I wanted to say he kind of he
come has to play it but what he didn't
soin I'd you form there is no night of
3m the rookie is hanging okay queen g3
right
okay look f8 look f8 takes Bishop d5
chick and I've got Bishop e6
yeah I was also threatening mate and it
was a funny mouth slip game yeah I
wanted to go d6 of course until L played
Bishop d6 yeah this is a position that I
had on the board already yeah a lot on
on my channel or streams interesting
line
yeah Bishop d6 is ridiculous so it's
it's a Mouse Club and yeah yeah I think
he did fine really fine
f4 was a move that I was not expecting
but it was was okay right the engine
likes it as well these six age three
yeah I thought I don't want to see g4 so
I won't that's why I went to age five
and I'm this is where it starts and the
engine engine likes 95 okay so this is
not the problem but then here right take
take 1993 and I did something that I
mentioned
now with 94 coming and the pawn is
hanging how caught that's terrible yeah
I when I when I looked at this during
the game I didn't even realize that this
is also attacked very well now you have
to you have to resort to stuff like that
which is terrible so the Queen c2 was a
mistake I'm giving giving away some of
the advantage and I thought here I'm
getting to something I'm getting getting
to be okay yeah and this is also what
the engine confirms is 6 yeah Queen d6
but that's probably not bad
and now he he stepped right into Knight
f6 which is a huge issue I could have
thought about I could have done that
maybe I can just take it oh my god okay
I need to I need to get get dinner now I
have six look at four it's actually a
mistake I should play c5 immediately
this so this is wrong why is Ruby for oh
wow oh my god
after that I'm just toast right I'm just
toast Wow didn't see that during the
game at all and yeah it's it's again
it's just winning him III calculated
this I actually calculated this which is
irregular
that is not an it's not illegal move
yeah that's it's irregular this is
completely wrong English I mean it's an
illegal move wow that was a very
effective mouth sleep I blunder
everything oh my god yeah I again
probably just need to know thanks a lot
for watching bye bye